the hit netflix show drive to survive
has brought formula one racing to a huge
new audience particularly in the us
weaving together the sports fierce
rivalries and electrifying action with
the aesthetics and heightened drama of
reality television it's tempting to see
a model that other sports could emulate
but in reality is that going to be
possible for streaming services
documentaries are a relatively cheap way
of getting into sports often costing
just several hundred thousand dollars
per hour of content compare that to
premier league soccer where the domestic
broadcast rights can cost in excess of
10 million dollars per game and of
course live sports have a shelf life not
many people are going to watch the
packers dolphins regular season game
three years after it was played but
people are still discovering the first
season of drive to survive several years
after it was released to understand why
drive to survive is so important to
formula one we need to look back to
2006. that's when the private equity
firm cvc acquired control of the sport
and in doing so it built up a huge
amount of debt in order to repay those
billions of dollars it had to make f1
more profitable and one of the main ways
it did so was by taking the sport behind
a paywall in markets where it was free
to air
the downside was of course that it
became hard to watch
in british households f1 was a staple of
sunday afternoon viewing after a slap up
sunday roast you might retire to the
sofa turn on the bbc and watch that
weekend's race
but in 2013 the paid tv station sky
sports acquired the rights of some of
the races and now holds all of them in
france a similar thing happened it moved
from the terrestrial channel tf1 to the
pay tv station canal plus
and audience numbers declined viewership
fell from 600 million people in 2008 to
closer to 350 million a decade later
none of this was helped by an era where
the red bull and then mercedes teams
dominated it became frankly a little bit
boring
and while the financial pop was getting
bigger there was a risk of diminishing
returns as the audience got smaller that
also made the sport less appealing to
advertisers
that's why drive to survive was such a
boon it reinvigorated flagging interest
in the sport particularly in the u.s a
market it had always struggled to crack
now there are going to be two further
races in the states in vegas and miami
and it's also provided a glimmer of hope
to other sports from tennis to rugby and
even volleyball private equity capital
is flowing to sport in a way we've never
seen before
the business plan is also largely
similar eek more money out of the
broadcast rights by either selling them
to a pay tv station or creating a new
subscription service
but again that comes with the risk of
losing fans
if you can replicate the drive to
survive model you can keep that audience
engagement
there is however a problem formula one
has some distinct advantages when it
comes to a multi-season reality tv style
approach it has a limited cast of
characters just 10 teams with two
drivers a piece and sometimes the
manager features two so at most a cast
of 30 characters
take it to soccer where each league has
400 or so players and it gets a little
bit trickier that relatively small list
of protagonists makes it easier to carve
out the rivalries that make drive to
survive so compelling
and the audience can build a
relationship with the drivers over
several seasons
amazon's all or nothing follows teams in
rugby soccer ice hockey and american
football but it moves on to a new team
each season you don't see both sides of
a given rivalry and you meet a new cast
of characters every year in drama terms
it's an anthology and its audience
numbers suffer as a consequence
other sports are still going to try in
fact the drive to survive team has just
signed a deal with netflix to produce a
show about the pga tour golf which
clearly has some similarities to f1 in
terms of the limited cast of characters
but it's also not quite the high octane
thrills and excitement that we are used
to with formula one
[Music]
you